do start in the east valley two metro
police officers shot and wounded this
morning metro says those officers were
investigating a murder from back in
november and that's when the fire fight
began early this morning hector mejia is
live now near nellis in vegas valley
with the latest on the officers
conditions and the investigation hector
we have learned the two officers are
expected to be ok they're at the
hospital recovering from gunshot wounds
and a source told the i-team they are
swat officers they were in that complex
you see across the street searching for
a murder suspect when they were hit by
the bullets you can see investigators
remain on the scene this afternoon
just after five monday morning gunshots
at the boulevard apartments in the east
side near nellis in vegas valley a
search warrant escalated to a shootout
between a suspect and swat officers when
many were sound asleep the suspect was
pronounced deceased at scene
both of our officers were transported to
a hospital where they're currently being
treated for their injuries a shattered
window layers of crime tape it's the
aftermath visible from this major road
we've learned the officers were doing a
follow-up investigation to a murder from
november of 2021 was the suspect killed
this morning the suspect in that
homicide it's preliminary details right
now i can't confirm or deny that we're
still investigating that
and this marks the second officer
involved shooting of the year for metro
police we expect to learn more details
in the coming days reporting in the east
valley hector mejia live local now